what should he be smoking the first time
smoker snoop and then I'll ask you said
I would say sativa yeah he's just start
with the T but because it's a little bit
lighter yeah it is more is more of a
introduction yeah I would probably
actually start with something strong to
make sure you go into the first no no no
no I think but I'm talking like what
percent should he start though I have
these like lower stage one but are they
routing the fun of we now we had to read
a [ __ ] menu I know it's a lot let's
see when you were weed outages yeah you
notice yeah we went through the book
just like any know that [ __ ]
front break exactly the whole menu
already I would probably get like a
strong like cuz there's like some lower
percentage weeds with which some people
like to smoke if they smoke weed all day
like like there's like 14 percent THC
which is like enough that you will get
high blessing but and if there's no
we're off it'll wear off but it it but I
think for someone who does never smoke
we you might want to start with actually
stronger we to make sure you actually
feel feel something because you might
not but I get one pitch one time you
want to get you right your fee for
Pierce's don't change your style a women
going change by the way
I should mention JD is wearing a special
shirt for his introduction you know with
the theme today this plant attack you
what's with this shirt something that we
recognize